foreign
[Music]
movie starring Margot Robbie and Ryan
Gosling is turning the world pink from
dream houses on Airbnb that you can rent
to Barbie themed home renovation shows
on HGTV to hot pink pop-up coffee shops
and Smoky pink sauce on a Whopper this
movie is literally everywhere but the
buzz is not just about anything pink
Ryan's bleached hair or Margaret Bobby's
feet director and writer Greta Gerwig
has also been stealing the headlines so
who is she and what are some message for
the world through Barbie let's take a
closer look
welcome to Bobby's dream house come on
in
Greta Gerwig was born on August 4 1983
in Sacramento California despite living
in a liberal State she attended a Roman
Catholic High School of which the
ideologies she said have stuck with her
until today
she actually based her first solo
directive movie ladybird on her own
upbringing you remembered
the film is about a teenager who tries
to discover her own identity while
attending a Catholic school now I
understand that you went to an all-girls
Catholic school that's right yeah yeah
like stereotypical like knee socks and
plaid skirts kind of thing yeah yeah the
nuns measuring like the length of the
skirt and all that kind of stuff we had
skirt check yeah but despite attending a
Catholic school gerwick was raised a
Unitarian Universalist a faith that
believes in many iterations of God
our beliefs are diverse and inclusive we
have no shared Creed our shared Covenant
our seven principles supports the free
and responsible search for truth and
meaning though Unitarianism and
universalism were both liberal Christian
traditions this responsible search has
led us to embrace diverse teachings from
Eastern and Western religions and
philosophies
after an attempt to enter Barnard
College in New York City to study
musical theater she ended up acting in
several low-budget movies her breakup
moment was when she was cast in Noah
baumbuck's movie Greenberg in 2010 which
starred Ben Stiller
Greta started dating Noah a year later
Noah actually co-wrote the Barbie movie
with Greta but we'll get back to that
later on in his 73 questions video by
Vogue Greta shares who her favorite
authors are but with someone in history
that you found to be really inspiring
someone is dead I am Virginia wool
Virginia Woolf favorite non-fiction
writer
uh Robert sapolski
Virginia Woolf has written a book called
Orlando my political biography a book
about the struggles of trans and binary
people which was published in 1928.
Robert zapolski is a neuroendocrinology
researcher whose beliefs in evolution is
not a secret despite his Orthodox
upbringing he considers himself an
atheist
[Music]
so now that we've created a bit of a
backstory of Greta gerwick let's take a
closer look at how her upbringing and
world view have shaped the brand new
Barbie movie in the Barbie movie we find
the main Barbie played by Margot Robbie
and all her Barbie friends live in the
perfect world there's no such thing as
death sickness sadness or anything even
close to it you know Barbie line is
perfect so it's really just maintaining
the order of perfection
um Compliments are absolutely essential
director Greta gerwick even comments on
how this idea of the perfect world stems
from her Catholic Education uh in the
movie it's like when it starts she's in
a she's in a world where there's no
aging or death or pain or shame or
self-consciousness and then she suddenly
becomes self-conscious which
that's a really old story uh that's we
know that story and I I think I kind of
always go back to those older story
forums
because I I don't know I went to
Catholic school and I resonate with them
something that we can see throughout the
storyline is the ideologies of a
religious movement called gnosticism
in a nutshell gnosticism stemmed from
the second century and is finding
popularity again today it was an
offshoot of early Christianity the
essence of what gnostics believe is that
humans are essentially Divine and their
purpose in life is to go higher up in
Divinity to eventually be equal to God
they do this by achieving Enlightenment
or knowledge who brings them such
Enlightenment Jesus Christ who in
gnosticism is not actually the biblical
Jesus but resembles Satan instead he is
the one who teaches them about this
Divinity within and how to become like
God in the Bible it was Satan who wanted
to become like God but never did instead
he was cast out of Heaven there's also a
story in the Bible of early humans
building a tower called the Tower of
Babel they wanted to reach the heavens
or reach God to become like him and
equal to him but God God confused their
languages which prevented them from
being able to continue to communicate
about the structure and they all went
their separate ways in gnosticism the
creator of the world is seen as evil and
the instigator of all sin who wants to
keep people trapped whereas in the Bible
the Creator who is God is love Satan
costs sin not God
you can see that it's basically the
Bible story flipped on its head God and
Jesus are considered evil for a Satan is
considered the Savior who brings
knowledge of how to become divine
so let's go back to the Barbie movie The
World Barbie lives in is perfect just
like heaven once was perfect look at how
the Barbie land has perfectly blue water
on the inside of the heart and green
grass but on the outside it is dry and
the waves look rough though dull in
color everybody is always having a good
time in this perfect realm I don't have
anything big planned just a giant
blowout party with all the Barbies and
planned choreography in a bespoke song
you should stop by so cool
it's the best day ever it is the best
day ever so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day from now until
forever there's even a reference made to
how this world in the movie is similar
to the world Adam and Eve lived in in
the Bible
they have no walls and that sounds very
simple they have no walls so everything
in barbinan is seen at all times you're
not normally with Adam and Eve as well
it's kind of like the naivety yeah
there's no shame there's no shame and
and there's no there's literally nowhere
to hide the interesting thing though is
that everything is made of plastic it's
all superficial and fake elements such
as water and fire don't exist it's all a
facade but then all of the sudden Barbie
starts displaying some imperfections
everything about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels are on the ground
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
in the Bible Heaven is a perfect place
and so was the earth before Adam and Eve
fell into sin yet despite it being
perfect it was never dull or fake or
artificial it was beautiful and everyone
was genuinely happy but in Gnostic
teachings Adam and Eve sought
Enlightenment and knowledge from no
other than Satan and it is portrayed as
a good thing as a way to be set free
eventually Barbie seems to question why
she's having these imperfections and
seeks out guidance from gymnast Barbie
look at how when Barbie walks up these
stairs to her Mansion everything still
looks colorful but also disorganized and
a bit wild the mansion looks chaotic and
so does gymnast Barbie her hair is a
mess and she's got pencil markings all
over her face who is this Barbie doll
who lives in a perfect world yet despite
portraying beautiful colors also shows
imperfection in the Bible we see Satan
in the Garden of Eden disguised as a
snake he tends Steve to take from the
fruit of the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil which results in sin
entering the world and Humanity in the
Gnostic writings however the snake Satan
is not actually evil but a being that
brings Enlightenment to Adam and Eve as
mentioned before he wants to help them
escape the tyrannical Creator and set
them free he is a kind of Savior
it is this confusion that we see with
this gymnast Barbie she she and her
Mansion are portrayed as colorful just
like the rest of the perfect Barbie land
yet something is off it is all chaotic
and disorganized imperfection in a
perfect world despite the similarity to
Perfection we know from the Bible that
Satan is in fact evil hence the chaos
and imperfection that this Barbie also
portrays listen to what actress Kate
McKinnon says about her character
gymnast Barbie weird Barbie has sort of
been
um relegated sequestered quarantined to
this space which is for weird house
which is a sort of freakish amalgam of
shapes and colors obviously that is the
manifestation of who she is in this
world which is like a shaman figure the
keeper of everyone's hidden weirdness I
like to think of myself
like that in real life too a shaman is
an individual in many occult and Eastern
religions that will connect a human with
the spirit world
again the goal of gnosticism is to
connect with the Divinity in yourself
and rise up and up to higher stages and
levels of the spirit world to eventually
become like God
this gymnast Barbie offers Margot
Robbie's Barbie an opportunity to go
into the real world Barbie has to choose
between high heels and Birkenstocks
what can I do you for I just had to come
see you about my feet they're
um
[Music]
flat
yeah never seen that before busy what
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world you can go back to your
regular life and forget any of this ever
happened or you can know the truth about
the universe
the first one the high heel
we'll do a redo
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the
universe you take the red pill you stay
in Wonderland
and I show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes the first one the high heel you
have to want to know okay do it again
Birkenstocks are shoes known to provide
arch support for those with flat feet
again Barbie is encouraged to embrace
her imperfections and go explore see
what's behind it all just like in the
Gnostic writings Satan encourages Adam
and Eve to seek Enlightenment and
knowledge and explore Divinity within it
is a way to discover their own identity
as Gods Eve in the Bible doesn't
immediately accept the fruit she first
questions the snake and says hasn't God
said You shall eat of the fruit of every
tree of the garden but of the fruit of
the tree of knowledge of Good and Evil
you shall not eat only after making the
statement that she take it and eat the
fruit Barbie does the exact same thing
with wanting the high heels first but
then accepting the Birkenstocks after
all the first one the high heel
we'll do a redo you're supposed to want
to know him again a reference to the
Gnostic teachings of enlightenment
Barbie enters the real world with Ken
where she faces everything imperfect
including sexual assault and getting
jail time just like the gnostics believe
in receiving Enlightenment to become a
greater Divine being within Barbie seeks
to understand what is in the real world
to become a quote unquote better version
of herself
as the gymnast Barbie said you're
supposed to want to know
to know something is to have knowledge
which is again to be enlightened
once Barbie leaves Barbie land she sings
along with the song Closer To Fine by
the Indigo Girls check out these lyrics
while Darkness has a hunger that's
insatiable and lightness has a call
that's hard to hear there's more than
one answer to these questions pointing
me in a crooked line and the less I seek
my source for some definitive the less I
seek my source closer I am to fine yeah
closer I am to fine
the Bible is considered a source of
something definitive a source of Truth
the scriptures also encourage followers
of Christ to walk on the straight and
narrow road and avoid the broad and easy
road that leads to destruction another
interesting observation is that both
Barbie and Ken leave the perfect Barbie
land just like both Adam and Eve left
the Garden of Eden a place of perfection
due to falling into sin or according to
the gnosticism because they sought
Enlightenment which is exactly what the
Barbie movie portrays
I'm coming with you okay we cannot
understand from just a trailer how the
movie will end but there is a trend in
Gnostic movies where the storyline
pretty much always ends with the perfect
world becoming imperfect and everyone
embracing imperfection think for example
of the Gnostic movies Pleasantville The
Lego Movie Wally's smallfoot and The
Truman Show
so how do we know that these were
actually director Greta gerwig's
intentions well there's some interesting
facts we can pick up left and right
for example as we mentioned earlier
Greta grew up in a Unitarian
Universalist household this is an
amalgamation of all kinds of religious
beliefs
everyone basically believes whatever
they want and there's no real structure
within all of this they themselves admit
that gnosticism has made its way into
their religious beliefs
the earliest Christians were known as
gnostics a number of their values and
beliefs are yet present in the tenets of
Unitarian universalism
spiritual threads of the Gnostic
writings run through not only Unitarian
universalism but neoplatonism and other
spiritual wisdom Traditions that have
tended the Flames of these ancient
candles of Gnostic wisdom form and Linea
Greta has also published a magazine of
various religious art in it we find a
photo of a cosmic tree known as the axis
Mundi the tree is used in various occult
and religious beliefs including
gnosticism it represents a connection
between Heaven and Earth again a
reference to the Gnostic beliefs of
having Divinity within and the goal of
reaching a higher and still higher state
of such until they can become like God
on the left of it we see a photo of an
art piece of the Egg of the universe in
gnosticism it is believed that this egg
contained a giant serpent that kept the
egg warm in the Bible the serpent is a
symbol of Satan she also mentioned her
favorite authors Virginia Woolf and
Robert sapolsky who have written about
transgenderism atheism and evolution
themes that we can also see in the
Barbie movie so why is the fact that
this movie has Gnostic ideologies a
problem or the fact that a trans woman
plays one of the Barbies and that there
is a big push for gender fluidity it is
a problem because there is such a thing
in our brain called mirror neurons the
name mirror neuron comes from the fact
that they fire both when you do
something and when you watch someone
doing something even if you like don't
move a muscle basically it's as if they
mirror the neural activity of the person
actually doing the thing in other words
by beholding we become changed but we
all with unveil old face beholding as in
a mirror the glory of the Lord are being
transformed into the same image from
glory to glory just as by the spirit of
the Lord if by behold of Jesus we can
become more like him it also works the
other way around science confirms this
biblical Doctrine another interesting
observation is that this movie has been
banned in Vietnam due to a map in the
movie that shows a politically
controversial dashed line in the Chinese
sea why would a country decide to block
an entire movie over a map that is not
even that well noticeable in the trailer
it's because they know how it affects
the subconscious and how it can lead
people to have a political view that is
against the country's leaders ideologies
so if that's the case can't a movie like
this with an underlying Gnostic
Antichrist and anti-biblical message and
a push for gender fluidity and
transgenderism not have an effect on you
too
beware lest anyone cheat you through
philosophy and empty deceit according to
the tradition of men according to the
basic principles of the world and not
according to Christ
foreign
[Music]